Mano, you're on stage.
>> Yeah, I'm doing good, bro. How are you?
>> I'm good.
>> So, I was listening to your conversation
and I I wanted to add something that the
brother was unable to convey.
>> I'm listening.
>> Can you please open the text again? So,
if you look at all these marks, the
dialect that you are saying direct, I
don't know what it's called in English,
but in Arabic, it's like zer. So what
the Quran used to be like was it was not
having these like dots and these like
marks before.
>> Yeah. So you would you wouldn't know how
to read it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. You would you wouldn't know how to
read it.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Like we don't know how to
read it. But the Arabic people like I
would say that was like another miracle
of prophet that he was like uh born in a
place where Arabics were very great in
their poetry. So like they they used to
call him. I think you must have known
that like the way he was conveying the
Arabic so it was confusing for them. So
that's why they used to call him a
magician. So how the Quran was revealed
was like it didn't used to have these
dots and the like different marks that
you are talking about like how you're
comparing the two.
>> Yeah.
>> So that won't make any difference if you
compare the two and that was like the
Quran how it used to be like
>> but it but but here there's a
difference. Do you agree?
>> Yeah. I'm telling you that it was not
like this. Like if you remove all
>> but but it is like this. If you if you
if you remove if you remove the
diritical marks, you don't know how this
is read. You don't know what this says.
>> But it will exactly be the same. And
that is how it was revealed. Like the
manuscript
was really quick. Let's cuz remember I
don't I don't have much time because I I
need us to get straight to the meat of
this. Without the diritical marks, you
wouldn't know what this said. Correct.
uh illited like me won't know but the
Arabic people used to know
>> the Arabic people they wouldn't know
this is this is why they came up with
this this is why they came up with diitr
how to read this because people would
read this differently right
>> please don't kick me out now because I'm
getting to you know and like I'm
teaching you how it's read actually
>> so according to these two versions are
these two different versions
>> no because
>> so do they do they say the same thing
>> have you seen the actual manuscript of
Quran the first Quran.
>> Brother, do they say the same thing?
>> I want you to look at the first
manuscript because
>> take care of yourself and about to waste
my time with you. Ali, you're up.
>> Hello.
>> Hello. Do you
>> Yeah, but every I think you actually
know the difference about crowds. So, I
don't know why you're asking about these
different crowds. It's like a well-known
situation.
>> All right, let let me see if you can be
Let's see if you can be honest with me
because my previous guests weren't. So,
I'm giving you a new chance.
>> Okay.
>> Are these different?
>> Yes. Thank you. What's the difference?
>> Well, the difference is uh they are both
Quran
>> and it's like they are different.
>> I understand. What's the difference
though? What's the difference between
these two?
>> Well, the difference is the the letters
are pretty much the same, but because of
the uh you know the dots and the signs
that are put there afterwards, you know,
the QR was originally revealed as a as
an oral book.
>> So, because of these diiocritical marks,
the grammar
and when it was reeled as an oral
>> brother just really quick please cuz I
we have to stay on the meat of the
matter.
>> So so due to the diritical marks here
>> between the two chaot changes what the
verse says correct.
>> I mean yeah
>> thank you. All right
>> it's not true though.
>> What do you mean it's not true? You just
said yeah. How do you what you just
said? You can have two different You can
have two different meanings. Like I'm
pretty sure you have two different
problem in the Bible as well.
>> No, no, we don't. This This has This has
two different You don't
>> Well, just
>> What do you mean you don't?
>> Hold on. Just I need you to settle.
>> You have You have like Ali. Ali, don't
do the Muslim shuffle. Don't do the
Muslim shuffle. Stay focused.
>> It's not a shuffle.
>> Stay focused. Ali, do you want to stay?
Ali, do you want to stay?
>> Well, stay focused. I want to be honest,
but stay focused.
>> Okay. ask me the questions.
>> Thank you. So, is the grammar of the of
each kyat here different in each verse?
>> The grammar the grammar I think the
grammar is pretty much the same.
>> Okay.
>> It's just the the way you
>> according to pronounce
>> hold on according to this
>> according to this one it says that Allah
would have made it known or I'm sorry he
would not have made it known to them.
Right.
>> Uh yes.
>> Correct. Nice. According to this one, it
says he would have made it known to
them, right?
>> I think so.
>> All right. Awesome. So, this one says he
would not have made it known. This one
says he would have made it known. Do you
Is that Is that a different meaning?
Does Does the meaning change?
>> Can you Can you read the whole sentence
as a whole?
>> Yeah. The whole sentence says that if
Allah had willed, I would not have
recited it to you. He and he would have
made it known to you. This one says, "If
Allah had willed, I would not have
recited it to you, nor would he have
made it known to you."
>> So if he wills, he he could have made it
known or he could have not made it
known. How is that a competition?
>> It's not about could he, it's about what
he would have done. If he w he would
have he just really quick if he willed
for Muhammad to not recite the Quran,
would he would Allah himself have made
it known anyway or would he not have
made it known anyway?
>> Uh can you please repeat your sentence?
>> My sentence is if Allah had willed for
Muhammad to not recite the Quran, would
Allah himself have made it known to them
or would he not have made it known to
them? Uh
I think it says had Allah w I would not
have recited to you nor would he have
made it known to you.
>> Exactly. So, so would he have made it
known to them or not?
>> Whatever he wills, he can do both.
>> Yeah. According to what he wills, would
he have willed to make it known or not?
According to the sentence,
>> I mean you need to I I think you are
really able to understand this. Whatever
Allah wills, he can made it known or not
made it known. It's like
>> I know I hold on. Let's let me let me
give you the difference between what
you're saying and what I'm asking.
You're saying that if Allah wills, he
could do either. He could do whatever he
wants.
>> I agree with you. I agree. So, you
understand? So, you see, I understand
what you're saying.
>> Now, I'm not talking about what he could
do
>> because he could do any of them. He
could do either or. But what I'm talking
about is what he would do. What would he
choose to do? According to the text,
it's not telling us what he could do.
It's telling us what he would do or not.
Okay. So, according to the text, would
he make it known or would he not make it
known? According to this
>> according to which one?
>> According to the one my
>> Yeah, it says not very good.
>> Nor would he made it known.
>> So, he would not have made it known.
Right. Now, according to this one, it
says that he would have made it known,
right?
>> Yeah. Had Allah failed, he can do both.
>> No, it's not. No, he can't. It's not
It's not both, bro. It's either or. It's
either if Allah willed for Muhammad not
to recite the Quran. Either Allah would
have made it known to them himself or he
would not have made it known to them
himself.
>> Yeah.
>> But both can't be true. It's a
contradiction.
>> It's it depends on what Allah wills. I I
know I know one is saying that he would
that he would not have done it. Wait,
listen. One is saying that he would not
have done it. The other is saying that
he would have done it. Which one is it?
>> Whatever he wills.
>> So So he wills a contradiction. Yeah.
>> No. If he wills, can I show you a
scientific scientific proof? Can I at
least show one proof?
>> No. No. There's a contradiction.